blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an entire
nonfiction book in just 15 minutes
you can try it for free and get 25 off a
subscription
by going to blinkist.com pakman
we are fortunate that under the joe
biden administration dr anthony fauci is
not holding back the actual science of
how things work and
of medical science and we know now
that during the trump administration
there was a friction
that made it to make it very understated
we could call it a friction
it made it so that there was a rift
between the science of coronavirus
and the trump administration's position
on coronavirus
since donald trump left we've been
hearing the science from dr
fauci and the white house has simply
been on board with that and that's a
very good thing
in this vein dr fauci yesterday or the
day before
responded to comments made earlier in
the week by fox news host tucker carlson
which we covered
where tucker suggested that uh parents
who make their children wear face
coverings
are engaging in a form of child abuse
and that if you see a child wearing a
mask you should call
child protective services to report
child abuse the entire rant was the
delusional by tucker
here's just a little bit of it as a
reminder if you dare to go on foot from
union station to the capitol for example
in washington without wearing a mask
angry biden voters will snort at you in
judgment how could you
they're saying from behind the gauze how
could you
that's the question we should be asking
of them in return
the rest of us should be snorting at
them first they're the aggressors
it's our job to brush them back and
restore the society we were born in
so the next time you see someone in a
mask on the sidewalk or on the bike path
do not hesitate
ask politely but firmly would you please
take off your mask
science shows there is no reason for you
to be wearing it your mask
is making me uncomfortable we should do
that and we should keep doing it until
wearing a mask outside is roughly as
socially accepted as
lighting a marble in an elevator it's
repulsive don't do it around other
people
that's the message we should send
because it's true as for forcing
children to wear mass
outside that should be illegal your
response when you see children wearing
masks as they play should be no
different from your response to seeing
someone beat a kid in walmart
call the police immediately contact
child protective services
keep calling until someone arrives what
you're looking at
is abuse it's child abuse and you are
morally obligated to attempt to prevent
it
if it's your own children being abused
then act accordingly
let's say your kid's school emailed you
to announce that every day after lunch
your sixth grader was going to get
punched in the face by a teacher
how would you respond to that that's
precisely how you should respond when
they tell you that your kids have to
wear masks on the soccer field
that is unacceptable it is dangerous and
we should act like it because it is
but too few of us have responded like
that so dr fauci was asked about this
and he responded in very clear
and incredibly certain terms
take a listen you know i think that's
self-evident that that's
bizarre uh jim i i don't want to get
into a back and forth
with tucker carlson but i mean it's just
almost self-evident you're talking about
child abuse really come on
now the problem of course is that
anybody who believes tucker to begin
with
is not likely to care what dr fauci says
i've spoken to many teachers because i
have many
friends that are teachers and they told
me you know the last thing we need right
now when we're trying to get
back to teaching is child protective
services
being called by fox news viewers because
the kids are wearing masks
if we are to think of the kids that's
not good for the kids
and then the other thing i've noticed is
kids really don't seem bothered by the
masks like i hate the masks i of course
wear them
but i don't like wearing a mask it's not
particularly comfortable
now that they're not required outdoors
as a vaccinated person i'm no longer
wearing them outdoors but the kids i see
with them and friends who have kids
and they talk to me about it they all
say the kids don't mind it at all
we seem to find it as adults we seem to
find the masks more annoying
than the children i would actually argue
that subjecting children
to tucker carlson's rants is way closer
to abuse than simply wearing a mask
at school and consider the position that
dr fauci has now been in for more than a
year he is a doctor
specializing in immunology during a
global hundred year pandemic and he ends
up
thanks to the trump administration uh
and of sycophants
like those of of fox news fame dr fauci
ends up in the position of having to go
on tv
to try to disabuse people of the
propaganda that comes
from the former administration dr fauci
goes on tv and has to try to disabuse
people
of tucker carlson's nonsense
disinformation remember that
fox news lawyers stated during a defense
of tucker carlson in a legal complaint
quote no reasonable person would take
tucker carlson
literally it is entertainment it is not
news he uses hyperbole he uses
exaggeration
and it's quite similar to the alex jones
defense of you can't go after alex jones
for things that he says on his show
because he is essentially playing a
character on his show
and certainly no one should take it
seriously jones or tucker carlson
but there are a lot of unreasonable
people who watch
tucker and do believe it's a news show
now my last thought on this
merely as a curiosity as a thought
experiment
what would happen if someone called
child protective services or even 9-1-1
and said
i'm calling to report that children are
being forced to wear masks
does anyone show up in certain
situations police have to show up if you
call with a certain complaint and then
say
sorry cancel it there are certain types
of things where police have to just go
and check things out
if you call and say children are wearing
masks would anyone even listen to you
or is tucker's suggestion if followed
just destined to be ignored by child
protective services now the other
strange thing about the anti-masters
is that many of them believe covid is a
lab-made bio-weapon from china
if you really believed that kovid was a
bioengineered bioweapon from china
why the hell wouldn't you be wearing a
mask that again is an example of where
a lot of these anti-science beliefs
conflict when you put two of them
together needless to say
hopefully not that much longer that dr
fauci will need to be on tv refuting
this nonsense maybe that's that's
optimistic thinking i don't know hey
this you have to see
a republican official who represents
orange county california named don
wagner
seriously asked during a hearing whether
covet 19 vaccines have a tracking device
in them now i know we see this on
facebook okay
your wacky uncle might be sharing it but
this is not your wacky uncle this is
well maybe it's someone's wacky uncle
this is an actual elected official it is
supervisor don wagner from orange county
representing many many people the
question came at an orange county board
of supervisors meeting
where the prospect of so-called vaccine
passports was being discussed
now we know that don wagner himself has
been vaccinated he tweeted back on april
3rd with a picture of himself
one and done with the johnson johnson
vaccine
start to finish was 45 minutes great job
to everybody
and thank you to dr chao for
administering my shot quick and painless
but
here is the same don wagner apparently
asking the same doctor chow it seems
who administered his vaccine about
tracking devices
you have to see it to believe it take a
look um it's
only at the patient's request that's
correct
does it do is there any intention of
tracking
folks nope
is there any in the vaccine we heard
about an injection of a tracking device
is is is that being done anywhere
in orange county i'm sorry i just have
to compose myself
there's not a vaccine with a tracking
device
embedded in it that i know of exists in
the world
period okay now i have some news for don
wagner that might be shocking to him
if he's worried about being tracked he
is
carrying around a tracking device all
day every day
it is his mobile phone the mobile phone
he carries around in his pocket
probably without a second thought has a
gps tracker
law enforcement if he were accused of a
crime could subpoena
access to his location depending on his
app permissions
apps can get access to his location it's
in his pocket
or sitting on his desk in front of him
as he asks whether the covet vaccine
has a tracking device in it this is
something i think about every time these
guys bring this up
the technology piece doesn't exist
to do this if you look at that syringe
it just it just doesn't exist but why
would you need to do it and i know
people will say oh but what about the
injected microchips into dogs
or dogs that's a dramatically different
size
and that is not a real-time tracker that
is something you can scan
if a dog shows up you can scan it for a
microchip it'll tell you the owner's
name completely different thing
not equivalent why go through the
trouble
of injecting billions of people globally
with a vaccine in order to track them
when they are already carrying around
gps enable phones
does he use a debit card or a credit
card which leaves a breadcrumb
trail of where he has been an atm card
which says where were you physically
withdrawing cash
does he wear a mask all day as he walks
around in front of hundreds of cctv
cameras and security cameras of various
kinds
my instinct is also that there's kind of
a moral hazard at play which is a funny
one in insurance there's this idea
that the people insurance companies most
want to insure
are the people who don't really need
insurance the people that really want
insurance
and can't afford not to have it are the
risks
that many insurance companies would
prefer not to take on my instinct here
is that the very people who believe
there's a microchip in the vaccine
are the people doing nothing that would
even be remotely interesting
or worthy of being tracked to begin with
why on earth
does government want to track like my
weird classmate from high school
who posts vaccine tracking conspiracies
to facebook
who works part-time at a garden supply
store and never
otherwise goes anywhere like who cares
where she's going does she think she's
so important
that the government even cares to know
where she is advertisers want to know
in order to sell her stuff but she's
already giving them that information by
using a smartphone
posting about her likes and dislikes on
facebook and the like by the way i
unfollowed her on facebook
it became completely unbearable but the
point here is
why would the government even want to
track
99.99 of these people to begin with it
is a
sad state of affairs out there and this
guy represents people
if you can imagine that let me know if
you've had encounters with these types
find me on twitter deepakman and tell me
tell me how you dealt with it i'm
curious to hear we have a great
program for you today glad you were with
us
what if you could read 10 books in just
one sitting that's
exactly what one of my favorite apps
lets you do it's called
blinkist and what they do is take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
they condense them down into text or
audio that you can consume in 15 minutes
blinkist makes sure that you're getting
all of the
important core insights from each book
so it's perfect for exploring a book you
otherwise wouldn't have time for
if there's a full book you're thinking
about buying you can use blinkist to get
a sample
first just think how much you can enrich
yourself
by being able to soak up an entire
nonfiction book in just
15 minutes i recently read a brief
history of time of course by the great
stephen hawking this is a book that i
have been aware of for so long
and other things got in the way and it
was fantastic
to check it out on blinkist blinkist has
books on politics philosophy
science they have 27 different
non-fiction categories
and a subscription is only about eight
bucks a month
and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get 25
off a subscription when you go to
blinkist.com
david pakman i've put the link right
underneath this video
of course you may not know because i
rarely mention it the david pakman show
is funded and supported directly by
members that means viewers and listeners
just like you
i've met many of them they really are
just like you
uh who sign up at joinpacman.com and you
can use the coupon code
immoral 21 to get a perfect
discount let's go to the phones
which are really just an internet voice
server
via discord you can find it at
davidpakman.com
discord the waiting lobby is where you
go to talk to me let's start with
harper from south carolina harper from
south carolina you are on the air
right now hi great to talk to you today
likewise so i was wondering
with i don't know have you heard about
kovacs yes
so what are your thoughts on that and do
you think that that's practical
yeah and what in what what specifically
would not be practical
well i've i've been thinking about it
and i was i was looking into it a little
bit and i saw that
it doesn't really there's still it
wasn't requiring the
the uh the richer more developed
countries
to not not have that priority
that they have with their deals you know
when they give
a hundred or like a hundred thousand
dollars or whatever
or that's not it a billion dollars to
pfizer to get however many doses
they still have those agreements so it's
it's not
actually getting people in less
developed countries
the doses that they need yeah you're not
wrong but here's the thing
soon the wealthier countries are going
to have all the vaccines that there's
demand for it's going to happen
relatively soon it'll feel kind of slow
because we're going through it day by
day but in a relatively short period of
time that's going to happen
so the fact that they've committed the
money i don't believe that the actual
distribution is happening any more
slowly because if the requirements that
you're talking about were in there
i think you'd have less buy-in so i
think that it's a way to get
financial commitments the vaccines are
not getting to poor countries nearly
quickly enough but i don't think they'd
get there any more quickly if you had
the requirements you're talking about
because a lot of the rich countries
would just say yeah it's not for us and
we're not going to put any money in
do you think there's any way around that
because what's happening in india is
just
disgusting and terrible i don't think
there is i mean
vaccines are starting to get to india
it's not going to help people that are
dying every day right now
now it's not going to help now yeah no i
i don't think there's any way around it
unfortunately
darn i was i was really hoping that you
had some miracle solutions no no by no
means what's happened there's no miracle
solution
coming to india other than the numbers
are slowing down at least the growth
rates are slowing down
okay that's good yeah that's good i
haven't heard updates since then yep
all right thanks harper appreciate the
call thank you
all right very good um we are
taking calls via discord and we are
going to hear
next from i hope i pronounced this
correct this correctly is it
saurabh from austin uh
hi i'm pacman yeah it's sarah
sarub okay uh what's going on uh
my question was regarding the minimum
wage sure why
does it have to be a fixed value why
can't be it be a dependent of couple of
factors
like the location as well as uh the
inflation rate
it absolutely can be i mean it's not the
way it's structured but i've i've
proposed this and i've said before that
state by state there are dramatically
different costs of living
and and prevailing wages and what counts
as a livable wage
is very different in rural alabama
than it is in new york city so i think
there's a couple of different things and
you're on to some of them
one would be to index inflation is tough
because i don't i don't know that we
have
different inflation numbers by state
i've
i've only ever looked at national
inflation numbers so you could index the
minimum wage in general to inflation
but i don't know that solve yeah that
would solve one of the problem that we
have to
keep updating these value every five
years or ten years
yeah and it it won't put a pressure on a
small businesses if they won't have to
increase just five percent every year
the wage rather than it being a chunk
like
a couple of dollars or five dollars
after ten years
no doubt no doubt i mean for me i think
the bigger differences would come
from adjusting the minimum wage based on
cost of living which is dramatically
different but then
here's a complicated question if a lot
of people
are working in one place but commuting
in from a different place
how do you account for that in terms of
is the cost of
is the wage adjusted to the cost of
living where they're working or where
they're living i mean there are things
to figure out
but i think that you're absolutely
correct in that
in a country as large and economically
diverse as the united states
i think you need a baseline minimum wage
below which no state goes but more
more nuance is probably better in this
case
yeah i agree all right how are things in
austin these days
yeah it's pretty good the climate is
very nice right now
i bet all right very good i appreciate
the call
thank you my pleasure uh let's see who
else we want to hear from there are just
so many people eager to get on
let's go next to ethan from santa monica
ethan you're on the air
hey yeah can you hear me i can hear you
yeah
uh okay cool so i was wondering your
thoughts on the
for the people act and more specifically
the action some democrats have been
proposing
to circumvent the filibuster remind me
which one
i rarely know proposals by their names
yeah that's hr one
oh hr one okay yeah yeah yeah of course
yeah okay
so obviously cinema and mansion have
said that they're not gonna
get rid of the filibuster as a whole yes
but the senate has amended it in the
past for budget reconciliation
right do you think the senate should
edit the filibuster for quote-unquote
democracy
reconciliation so that only 50 votes are
required
in order to pass hr1
i don't know i don't know if there's a
better alternative yeah i don't know and
i've talked about this before
i think that just doing away with the
filibuster
uh changing from 60 to 50. i do believe
it's a double-edged sword and what we've
learned
is that these completely amoral
right wingers will use every tool they
have
against democrats when given the
opportunity and then they'll
act outraged when democrats do the same
thing a great example is the merrick
garland nomination in obama's last year
and then
putting amy covet barrett on the supreme
court within like a week or whatever you
know
they're just total hypocrites so the
question is
one do we quote stoop to their level
with the filibuster i don't have any
uh moral opposition however i worry
about how it would ultimately come back
to backfire dramatically against
democrats i think that
from what i've read i like the idea of
going back to it being
a real talking filibuster and requiring
40 people in the chamber at all times
in order to keep debate going this will
do two things it'll make it logistically
more difficult for republicans to keep
it up
and then number two it will also make it
more
publicly visible when republicans are
being obstructionists
so i'm kind of leaning in that direction
i've not seen like
something super convincing that says
just blow up the filibuster altogether
right now
well do you think that could actually
last
indefinitely because obviously right now
as it is
they can basically completely block hr1
from passing
and if they continue to like you know
if it's a talking filibuster obviously
the intention with that
is that uh they wouldn't be able to do
that indefinitely which is
sort of their whole point of the
filibuster yes uh
you're saying if that's what democrats
decided to do
in terms of a rule change couldn't
republicans then just undo that as well
next time they take control
exactly yes they could but my point is
it might be a way
to get some things done now without
blowing it up altogether which could
backfire dramatically
yeah i guess you know especially if if
they uh
institute some sort of uh 50-vote
alternative for
uh democracy reconciliation i think you
know if republicans somehow get a
trifecta they could
completely use that to you know add all
these uh
voting restrictions and all that
nationally so right i guess
it just depends on your sort of
philosophy per person
yeah and i'm also thinking about it from
a pragmatic standpoint which is
what are ways to get some things done
now without then
having disasters happen in the future in
an almost certain way and it's a
complicated thing i don't know the
answer i think
what i feel strongly about though is
just leaving it the way it is now is
not likely to be the best outcome okay
all right thank you so much all right my
friend thank you great question very
very important topic and will be
uh uh a determining factor i would say
in what successes there are
in this uh first couple of years of joe
biden's presidency
let's go where else are we going to go
let's go to
uh let's go to jack from belgium let's
hear from an international caller jack
you're on the air
hey david thank you the goal again my
pleasure
i i've had two uh smaller questions
today
okay um the my first question was
um whether you think the main reason
that the first hundred days
of biden now seem good because everybody
had
kind of low expectations after trump
uh instead of well his actual
accomplishments
um i know i feel like his
accomplishments have been have been of
course
positive for the country but um i just
feel with everybody's expectations this
low
maybe that made him seem better
beautiful okay so i think that you're
right to a degree
but i would say my my
grade for joe biden for his first
hundred days
which is you know it doesn't really
matter what the grade is but it's pretty
good
i think that it's about 90
what biden did and 10 that he had low
expect we had low expectations because
of trump so i agree with you
in part but i think that if you actually
compare joe biden's first hundred days
i would say to any recent president joe
biden has
objectively gotten a lot done would i
like to have seen more
of course but um i i actually think it's
mostly that biden has actually done
things
yeah all right yeah of course i've seen
the positive things that he's done and
i'm
also happy with them yeah so i i would
agree
well and my other question was whether
you think he'll keep up the momentum
until 2024 to to hopefully get the
second presidency
um because i i'm afraid that he'll slow
down by the end
um and not um
i'm thinking of this in a two-year
sprint
i'm thinking of what happens between now
and 2022.
if in 2022 republicans take the senate
and or the house
the dynamics for 2024 are completely
different
so rather than worrying yet about 2024
we don't know if trump is running we
don't know anything about 2024
what we know is that in 2022
there could be a complete change in the
balance of power i'm focused on these
two years and i think that for now
biden has three big things that he's
going to be continuing to work on
uh some of which he announced at his
wednesday night speech
so let's focus on these two years first
uh of course yeah well i i think the
house is pretty much
um well i heard about a lot of
gerrymandering is gonna happen with the
republicans yeah
um which is got basically gonna give the
house to the republicans as far as i've
heard
i don't know which sucks but yeah
well yeah we'll see we'll see i'm
pranked for that
but the senate is looking decent at
least yes
i mean listen i in 2019
i thought democrats would not take the
senate in 2020 but
might take it in 2022. they took it in
2020 and maybe they can even build on
the majority in 2022
well i would really like to see that i'd
be very happy for that
remind me what part of belgium are you
in uh anthrop i'm from antwerp oh right
right right right
beautiful beautiful city i've been it's
oh nice
yeah of course and i think i don't know
if i asked you this last time
as far as french fry uh
sauces go what are your favorite sauces
i i personally really like samurai sauce
it's very spicy
um it's got a good bite to it i really
like separate
is it a ketchup is that a ketchup based
sauce uh
well it's it's more uh it's it's a whole
bunch of
it's kind like kind of like uh we got
cocktail it's like mayo and ketchup
together with oh
okay okay okay i like that but i must
say
sorry as a belgian um the the fact that
so many americans call them french fries
i know i know they're really they're
belgian frites right
so i just wanted to point that out i
know
i apologize i made a mistake okay
well thank you and thank you for taking
my call thank you
all right very good uh thank you so much
for the call
always want to be checking in with all
sorts of different people
and we will check in with more people
momentarily if you're holding don't hang
up we're going
to a quick break and we will be right
back after this
dealing with the paramount issues of our
time including french fried doneness
we've addressed
sauces we will address crispiness after
this short break okay don't hang up
the number one funding source for the
david pakman show
has been and continues to be membership
and membership is not just a feel-good
thing
you get access to the world famous bonus
show every single day
just for members as well as commercial
free audio
and video feeds of the show day in
and day out you can sign up for
membership very very quickly
at joinpacman.com that's join pakman.com
if the normal prices strike you as high
by all means use the coupon code
better21 all one word all lowercase
become a member today let's go back to
the phones by which i mean our discord
voice server which you can find at
davidpakman.com
slash discord there are so many people
uh hoping to get on let's talk to some
of them
why don't we go to ryan from dallas
texas ryan you're on the air
hi david can you hear me i can hear you
fine
uh hi david um so you know i'm a young
black man
and you know i don't really consider
myself to be too liberal or
conservative i kind of find myself in
the middle okay um
and i and i don't really like to cry
wolf for every single
issue with the minority i like to assess
it based on case-by-case basis
but my question for you is you know jim
crow only ended
56 years ago and there was there really
wasn't anything significantly done to
try to uplift you know and compensate
the black community
for all those years of uh oppression yes
and my question to you is what do you
think
should have been done and at the time
and what do you think we could do
now well the problem at the time was
that as we
have very much learned simply changing
the rules on paper
to outlaw certain types of
discrimination
it number one doesn't actually eliminate
the discrimination
right away and number two it doesn't
actually
set people up on an even playing field
i've used the monopoly analogy before
uh if a new player enters a monopoly
game after a few people have been
playing for an hour
on paper you can say everybody's playing
by the same rules but all the
properties have been purchased and the
bank already has relationships with the
existing players
etc okay that's the analogy so i think
that was the missed opportunity then
now i don't know if you're getting
towards the idea
of of reparations or not my thoughts on
this and people
people get very angry with me some
people get angry with me when i say it
but
this is an issue i've looked into to a
significant degree i don't claim to be
an expert on it i have not seen
evidence that sort of throwing money at
people
is actually going to solve the issues
that remain as vestiges of the slavery
and jim crow
era throwing money at people won't solve
a lot of the geographic structural
issues that we have in terms of
uh neighborhoods and public transit and
a lot of other different things it won't
at least not in any direct way solve
some of the education
inequalities that exist so i am open to
the idea
of a reparative process but i'm more
interested in seeing
how it can go to structural change
rather than necessarily like
tossing money at people right i
completely agree um
i definitely think that there needs to
be a new basic standard for
you know i mean simply stuff stuff like
apartments you know a lot of these
people are living in these apartments
that are just
or i mean just horrid apartments i i
used to live
in some terrible apartments rat and
festival when i was when i was little so
and also schools you know they're so
underfunded and you have
these schools in the suburbs buying you
know new stadiums so
i i i'm completely on board with that
now let me ask you this you said that
you're not
super left or right what's an issue on
which you consider yourself a centrist
like is there a social issue where
you're a centrist
um for instance you know this bill that
came out about the equality act
you know i completely agree that there
needs to be some formal
you know um regulation on uh
not being discriminated because of your
gender identity and things like that
but like i don't agree with that gin you
know that they should be able to play in
the
sport that they identify with i guess i
guess in my opinion that's
being neutral but i don't now hold on
does that apply to all sports or only
certain
sports um i honestly haven't thought
about it that much
um you know i i guess in my mind
i would initially think about the more
physically
um you know uh where you know where it
fit where your physical
um stature is more important and more
significant
but i guess i guess maybe it's just a
defense mechanism because i want people
to actually listen to me
versus just making assumptions about me
because you know i'm a young black guy
so it almost sounds like in a sense you
are taking some of these positions to
posture as something other than a
liberal
um maybe i i
maybe that could be the case yeah i
would think about that i i definitely
don't think that i'm
i'm more liberal than conservative for
sure you don't think so or you are more
liberal than concerned no
no i i'm definitely more liberal than
conservative i see yeah that's coming
through that's coming through yeah
all right my friend thank you for the
call i appreciate it all right thank you
all right take care oh we are hearing
from people via discord davidpakman.com
discord uh the waiting lobby is the
place to
signal your interest in getting on air
with me
why don't we go next to um
let's go to annette annette you are on
the air
annette you can unmute and then we'll be
able to chat
annette i would love to speak to you but
i can't if you mute yourself
and i would uh give you just this one
last opportunity of course
with peace and love all right
no annette that's really too bad that's
a shame
let's go to alex from orange county next
alex you're on the air
hey how are you doing david i'm doing
well
um have you um um read about the
sentences or um heard about the
the latest simpsons um recently i have
now i have to ask
what's playing in the background right
now
my um that's my mom's um tv do you want
me to move or
it would be a yeah it will you and i
will be able to communicate so much
better if there isn't a tv going in the
background
the census yes we've covered the census
the u.s has
331.4 million people living in it
according to the census
it is the slowest rate of population
growth dating back
a very long time and it will lead to
two more congressional districts for
texas and then there are some states
going plus one
some states going minus one so that's
the census so far
all right dude how's my audio beautiful
all right so yeah i um i heard all about
that but my concern
is on the dexter scheme the districting
and the
um congressional seats and how the
gop might gerrymandered the way into
like
a house majority yes so my understanding
and tell me if this is your
understanding
is that the national census is used to
determine
how many seats each state has but it's
up to
each state to draw the lines some states
use a sort of nonpartisan districting
commission others it's more legislature
based is that your understanding of how
that works
yes yeah so it's a concern it's a
concern because you take a place like
texas and i admit i've not looked at
exact at how texas will do this
you look at texas they you get two more
congressional seats
they could gerrymander the hell out of
them i don't know if you've seen dan
crenshaw's district
uh it's gigantic i mean it's just it
looks like a crescent moon it makes no
sense whatsoever
and that's why that district is a
republican district so i that's a huge
concern
yeah so um correct me if i'm wrong but
isn't
gerrymandering illegal well
the the the thing about that is it is
against
the it is against the law to
do it in a way where you were
deliberately disenfranchised
a protected class of people but the
thing is proving that in court that's a
huge process and every once in a while
like i think there was a decision in
north carolina in the last few years
where
a judge found that's what they did
you've got to redraw
but that's a really expensive and long
process and so you can
you can often still get away even if
that's what you've done you can still
get away with it often for one or two
election cycles until until the legal
system catches up with it
okay um is there any way that
um even though we have the majority the
democrats have the
um are the leaders of the house and
slightly in the senate is there
any way that the democrats could like
prevent gerrymandering
i i mean so so democrats
in the house and senate and joe biden
could put together
in fact hr one may have some
gerrymandering related provisions in it
you could pass something like that at
the federal level
uh but then you will have lawsuits from
states
and then it'll have to be adjudicated
and uh it's going to take some time
so can it be done in time for 2022
i i don't know it really is a state
process and so when you have the federal
government trying to regulate a state
process you will always have some states
who say
that's outside of your purview and so
it's it gets
the theoretical answer is yes the
practical answer of whether it can be
done before 2022 is a question mark
okay so um with all that um considering
how do you feel about the
2022 midterms i'm worried i'm more
worried about the house than the senate
is how i would say it right now
but i think it's a little too early to
say
if joe biden continues doing well in
getting things done
i think it's better if joe biden falters
and
trump remains popular and gets involved
as a king maker
it could look pretty ugly for democrats
in 2022.
tell it okay
looks like we lost them i appreciate the
call very much and i'm glad to have
been able to answer at least some of
your questions let's talk to
um why don't we go to andrew
from miami andrew you're on the air
hi david can you hear me hi ken
hey so i was curious what your opinion
was of nancy pelosi recently
um investing 10 million dollars in
microsoft i didn't know that she did
what she bought 10 million dollars worth
of
microsoft stock correct around a month
ago she invested upwards of 10 million
in microsoft stock and then shortly
after that microsoft received a
government contract for
a pretty large sum of money and then the
stock went up
you know there's a lot of stuff about
nancy pelosi
that is that is untrue and i want to be
careful because
there's a rumor that nancy pelosi is
worth 196 million
but it seems she's really only worth
five million dollars
so when you're telling me she invested
10 million i i just
i haven't heard that and i'm just unsure
about that i
i think her husband is quite wealthy i
don't know
because of all of the the incorrect
stuff i just don't know
yeah her husband just owns a major
investment firm so he
has ties to wall street and then she
directly acts on legislation that would
affect the stocks that she invests in
yeah i mean listen i've come out before
and i've said
um that it is too easy to violate the
stock
act for members of the house and senate
there are real questions about
that being not nearly regulated enough
and i apply that to republicans as much
as democrats
specifically nancy investing 10 million
when as far as i know her net worth is
five i just i
just don't know about that gotcha yeah i
mean just in light of her recent
comments as well after the shogun
uh trial it just seems like she's a
liability democrats and she's yeah her
comments about the chauvin thing were
for people who don't know she said
something like i want to thank george
floyd for sacrificing himself in the
name of
justice or whatever it's like whoa hold
on a second he didn't he didn't
sacrifice himself and that's really
strange language and it seems insane
insanely insane that was just major faux
pas yeah
i agree so it seems like she's a
liability to dems and it almost seems
like she wants republicans to win in the
midterms
i don't think she wants republicans to
win i just think she's making missteps
why would she want republicans to win
it would lengthen her ability to
continue fighting for corporations as
opposed to actually
people's interests nah nah that doesn't
ring i
i don't think so i i think nancy pelosi
certainly to some degree is
you know focused on herself but i have
no reason to think she wants republicans
to win
interesting thanks so much david all
right pleasure great to hear from you
uh okay let's see who else we can hear
from because we really have been having
some beautiful phone calls today
um excellent excellent calls let's
talk to uh lucas
from hendersonville where is
hendersonville by the way
hey uh it's north of nashville oh okay
hendersonville
um tennessee very beautiful okay yes sir
thank you um my question to you is that
there is about
10 million illegal immigrants in the u.s
what steps should biden take to
[Music]
help accommodate those people into the
american society
that we have today well i think you have
to
kind of go in in stages
and the first thing is daca has to be
dealt with there has to be a permanent
solution on daca um it's hard for me to
to lay out a full policy sequence
because so much of it depends on if how
and when
daca is dealt with um i do think that a
clear path to citizenship should be put
in place
uh i mean i don't have any any unique
particular view on this it's
it's what uh you know i i like what
people like ro khanna have talked about
on immigration
and um you know congressman ruben
gallego and and others
uh just just kind of a just reasonable
uh
system where we're treating people with
respect
and we're understanding that the vast
majority
of undocumented immigrants are here
working paying into systems
and raising families etc yeah i don't
have anything
groundbreaking on that thank you
my pleasure appreciate the phone call
okay
that is going to close today's call
session
i of course am deeply sorry that i was
not able to get to more people but we
we do operate with a time limit and we
are going to be back with many more
phone calls
very very soon we'll take a quick break
and be back with much more after this
the david pakman show is audience
supported media and you can contribute
any amount you want on patreon as little
as one dollar per month
plus you can get the daily bonus show
world famous at this point
and the daily commercial free tv show
by making those pledges at patreon.com
slash david pakman show this is audience
supported media we depend on the support
of our viewers and listeners
whether you listen to the podcast watch
on youtube or watch us on tv
or even listen on the radio patreon.com
davidpakmanshow okay let's get into
audience questions for the week the
first question
is david why did so many more minority
voters vote
trump in 2020. these are very
interesting numbers and we've talked
about a little bit of the why but as a
reminder
from 2016 to 2020 trump
improved six points with black men
three points with white women five
points with black women
four points with hispanic men five
points with hispanic women
and then plus seven with asians and
other minority ethnicities so i think
that there's a couple of different
things going on
some of it is strictly mathematical and
some of it is more ideological
the first let's go to the ideological
part first i've pointed out
that in the 2020 campaign
because of the pandemic trump getting
covered
the focus being biden and his socialism
and his dementia and all of these
different things
by by coincidence not because trump
decided
i'm gonna be less racist this uh
this'll you know i'm not gonna talk
about mexican rapists and all this stuff
but just because trump was busy with
other things
he was less overtly antagonistic
to minorities other than the whole china
virus thing which
resonated with a lot of people actually
so that it's not clear that that really
did him much harm
um and so by just being distracted with
other things
there was less of the overt xenophobia
from trump in 2020 than in 2016. there
wasn't none of it
and and you can still find many examples
but there was less of it
overtly which probably had some factor
but i believe that the answer to how did
trump gain with minority voters i think
it's actually more of a mathematical
thing voter turnout in general
was much higher in 2020 about six
seven full points higher that's millions
of people
and it's less in my mind that
trump converted minority voters that
voted for hillary in 2016 and they voted
for trump in 2020.
it's that a ton of every demographic
group didn't vote
at all in 2016 and
from that group trump was able to get
people out in some particular districts
areas and states
so when i look at the numbers and we
have this id
there are people who say people on the
right who say
the real racists are the democrats and
over time
minority voters are going to realize
this they're going to move to the
republican party
uh and and some of those people are
saying these numbers are
evidence of it the fact that trump
gained six points with black men and
five points with black women
et cetera the other side of it is
um that this is a one-time uh sort of an
anomalous or anomalous
situation and that um it's really just
because turnout was particularly high
for everybody and joe biden's
margin of victory is what we should be
paying attention to which was a
really big margin of victory i think we
just can't resolve it in one election
cycle i think that you have to wait and
see
um what happens in future election
cycles
and i don't think it's completely
resolved and we're actually going to
talk
in the next question about
college-educated whites leaving the
republican party like are they actually
leaving is it a realignment what does it
mean a lot of these things are more than
one election
cycle there's one other hypothesis
which is one that the right likes a lot
of kind of small
government libertarian think tanks like
it which is that
they believe minorities are quote
natural republicans that
if they were more politically engaged
they would naturally go more towards
republicans
partially because some of them have more
religious backgrounds a lot of catholic
latin american immigrants
republicans say would naturally be
republicans if they had a higher voter
turnout
a lot of socially conservative black
americans would more naturally go to the
republican party if they had higher
voter turnout were it not for
propagandizing and democrats lying to
them and
all those different stuff i think the i
think it's just a hard no i think that
you know as someone myself who
who is from argentina and have seen
latin american catholicism firsthand it
is not
the hard right evangelical christianity
that leads people to vote for people
like ted cruz
that's not what we're talking about when
we talk about most
latin american catholics i don't think
there's a natural home in the republican
party for that group
and um i you know the the idea that
black voters only vote for democrats
because they've been tricked
is also there's absolutely no evidence
behind it whatsoever so
i don't buy that hypothesis we will see
in 2022 and 2024 what happens with
minority voters my view is we don't have
enough information yet to say whether
the gain
that trump saw from minority voters in
2020
means anything long-term or if it's a
one-time change because of the
particular dynamics of the 2020 election
okay next question is very related to
the first one are the college-educated
white uh voters actually becoming
more liberal um there's a very
interesting dynamic that's going on here
with college-educated whites
i talked to you must have been about a
month ago
about the abandonment among some
of the republican party moving to the
democratic party or moving to be
independents who still may vote for
republicans or whatever the case may be
it is absolutely true that this has been
a shift over time
among college-educated white voters
college-educated white voters
some decades ago leaned much more to the
right and it was primarily for economic
reasons
the idea and this came up during the
voicemail segment on monday
the idea being college-educated people
are more likely to make more money
and they want to keep the money so they
vote for republicans because they see
republicans as keeping their taxes low
and that's a very nice concise little
explanation
and certainly some decades ago there was
probably a lot of truth to that
however we've now seen more
college-educated whites
over time move in the direction of
voting for more and more
democrats i think that there are two
things going on here number one
although the republican party is still
seen widely as the low tax
party the daylight between the two
parties has gotten smaller and smaller
now i know joe biden now is talking
about doubling the capital gains rate on
people making over a million dollars and
all these different things but
the vast majority of people don't make
over a million dollars and so when you
think about
college-educated democrats uh
college-educated voters
making between you know 80 and 180 000
or something like that um they may
actually be realizing
you know the the very small difference
in what i might pay in taxes under the
republican versus democratic plans
is not enough to override all the other
reasons that the college-educated white
voter
has been moving to the left and this
includes social issues
this includes cultural elements as well
so while the economics are always
reflexively what we might go to
social attitudes have changed as well i
mean look at something like approval of
black lives matter
in 2017 if you polled white
college graduates do you support black
lives matter
29 said yes i do that same poll
uh right now has 40
of white college graduates supporting
black lives matter
that's an increase of almost 33 remember
not 30 it's 11 percentage points but
about almost a third about 30 percent
that it appears significantly overrides
oh
my the top tax bracket is three points
lower
under the republican plan and so
that to me seems like a major
factor in what we've seen from
college-educated white voters
moving more uh to the democratic party
the other thing also that may be going
on is that
as people simply become more politically
aware
they make more rational decisions about
where they say
they align before trump one of the
things that
trump did and we saw it in
absolute record turnout in 2020. trump
getting way more votes than he got in
2016.
biden getting way more votes than anyone
has gotten um
so one of the things that we saw trump
do
for better or worse is engage a lot of
new people
and there are likely lots of
college-educated white voters
who are recently out of college who were
in some nominal way kind of following
the politics of their parents maybe
maybe you maybe had some really you know
21 22 20 year old
uh in college or college graduates that
in 2015
were republicans in some nominal way but
maybe they didn't vote for example as
they became more politically aware i'm
not using
the term woke but as they became more
engaged in politics during the trump era
and they more understood oh wait a
second yeah i don't know what my parents
saw in the republican party but i don't
see it with trump i'm going to become a
democrat for example um i think that
that's a factor as well
that sometimes you just have people who
more as they get more involved they
understand that whatever they were
nominally identifying with originally
really wasn't for them and so that may
be something you see in the numbers
that may not not actually reflect a
shift it may simply reflect a change
from not paying attention to paying
attention
some things to think about let me know
your thoughts on this one last question
today david do you believe
that people whose hobby is politics
actually get anything done
politically this is a i want to be
careful in how i talk about this because
if i were to say people who just follow
politics
as a hobby and source of entertainment
don't get a damn thing done
i think it would potentially be
disaffecting to many people
my view is that and we we've done
interviews on this before and it's an
important question we've talked about it
with rachel bittikoffer and with other
people
political hobbyists don't get much done
themselves if they only remain political
hobbyists
however they may number one
by sharing information on social media
get
other people to go beyond being merely
political hobbyists and being
actual political activists who get
things done but for many people being a
political hobbyist
is the entry path into being more of an
activist someone who actually calls
elected officials organizes
uh does voter registration volunteers
for candidates etc
etc etc so if the question
you it's the devil isn't how you ask the
devil's in the details of the question
do people who never go beyond merely
following politics like entertainment
help to achieve
change very very little hopefully they
at least vote not all political
hobbyists even vote but to the extent
that they do voting is important
if the question is can being a political
hobbyist
lead to being someone that actually does
achieve change by becoming an organizer
or someone who volunteers for campaigns
or whatever else the answer is
absolutely yes and i know
tons of people and many are in our
audience who started just by watching
shows shows like this and
and other shows and voted but then
eventually
really became engaged and i can think of
people in lots of different parts of the
country where
that's the case so what is important is
not to
dismiss those who are interested in
politics
and follow it as a hobby as people who
can never get anything done
it's a matter of encouraging them to get
more involved
and there are so many ways that that can
be done either running for something at
the local level volunteering
for a local state or national election
and doing phone banking and text banking
and all these different things
people who one other thing right now
the candidate that raises more money in
a race is more likely to win it's not
100 it's not correlated at one
but there's a correlation between
raising more money and being able to uh
and ultimately winning
if you become a political hobbyist and
you donate money
you are also involved in a way that
materially affects outcomes
i wish that it wasn't the case that our
political system depended on money in
that way
it's a disgusting corrosive system that
must be changed
but if you're not only a political
hobbyist but someone who donates
to candidates that you believe in you
are also having an impact and we know
that and there's a reason that raising
money is so important and and such a
important factor in signaling who might
actually win an election
so let's embrace the political hobbyists
to do more
rather than writing them off as people
who make no difference and the truth is
most people in my audience are political
hobbyists
some percentage of them are more than
that
and hopefully we can encourage that
number to grow even further
let me know your thoughts we also have a
great
bonus show for you today the bonus show
is
only exclusively for our website members
and patreon donors you can sign up
at joinpakman.com you can sign up at
patreon.com
david pakman show either way you'll get
instant
access to the bonus show why not do it
before
april is gone you have just hours to go
i'll see you then
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors blinkist is the
app that helps you become a more
well-rounded person by letting you read
or listen to an entire nonfiction book
in just 15 minutes
you can try it for free and get 25 off a
subscription
by going to blinkist.com david pakman